all right so the girl power is a real
thing on this show I loved it you two
collaborating as EPS mark and Billy said
they were intimidated by you two ladies
as their bosses we did our job
they're so full of it they were never
one second not one minute very very kind
of them actors and creators in their own
right and multitudes of work that I'm
very respectful of and excited about but
yeah it takes having that level and
caliber of actors to collaborate with
and I'm enormous ly grateful to them for
us deciding to be part of this project
which is a huge cultural conversation
for men and women yeah yeah as two
people who have been on the receiving of
morning shows now playing journalists
did it give you a different perspective
at all well we know well we now know
what we pulled the curtain and we know
that now what they were going through
and struggling with and tolerating for
for so so long it wasn't just a perky
Robin Roberts in the morning you know
what I mean who would just be gracious
and lovely and talk to you about your
meg Ryan movie or ten minutes yeah we
just know more we just have more
awareness of what goes on yeah the
negotiations for their deals the
mistreatment the quality the inequality
the pay inequality all these things are
in our show and it really bring it all
to the surface yeah yeah I know that you
guys said I think the first time you
guys met was on set
now so much time has passed
what is your dynamic like now working
together well we're older we're wiser
thank God
yeah thank God and have a lot more
experience under our belt and it's been
wonderful to to be able to now put forth
all of those years of of work and and
and you know everything that we've
learned and put it into a project that
we're so proud of from the ground up
with a new streaming service and it all
feels very very exciting to be in such
an amazing company and with a television
show that is just so beautifully written
and characters that are so rich and it's
a big undertaking I mean it's a big the
scope of the show is he's huge and I
don't think anyone really understood and
it was a it was a interesting first year
relief
okay let's carry on yeah
and obviously welcome back to TV yes did
you encourage this or was this like a
long time coming were you planning this
like how did this work out I mean I
wasn't thinking I was just trying to get
you know find something that I loved to
do and it's not always easy because
there's not a lot of great shows out
there for women or at least that I was
being you know given the opportunity to
do be a part of and this came up a
couple of years ago 20:16 allenford
asked us both and it was a no-brainer in
terms of this is a perfect this is an
actually perfect thing to become a part
of yeah
and for you just being excited to do
I'm excited for my partnership with Jen
that you know with getting to work with
Steve Carell playing this incredible
character that's so detailed and nuanced
and getting to collaborate carry Aaron's
words are so fun to say they're hard to
memorize but really fun so when you just
memorize them
mark Duplass is so fun to work with and
Billy Crudup watching him create this
character was fabulous
me me leader moving the camera in ways
that you're like oh my god we're gonna
do this on one right right it's just so
exciting but terrifying and it's just it
was a dream project and you're tackling
issues that you're talking about over
dinner tables and in a you know in the
workroom and and I thought wow to be
playing something fun and talking about
cultural conversation is really a dream
yeah